so do you need to like are you telling
your mom like yo you got a knock on the
door of my bedroom mom if you need me
for anything like I do you have the
space that you need to know to create -
right is it all just everything's going
back to being a high school yeah they've
never knocked for anything but yeah I
mean in terms of like you know creating
and stuff like I've been trying to like
it's funny I was just talking to
somebody else about this like there's
this quote that I love that's Aristotle
said that was freedom is obedience to
self formulated rules you know and and I
love that because I also it's so true
for me at least like that you know if
I'm in my like working in LA and I'm
watching TV when I get home like all
night or whatever I feel like I feel
like you know like and but but if I've
set a goal for myself and I kind of
complete it and it doesn't not to say
like don't enjoy yourself and don't
watch Netflix and well you should I mean
it's amazing but it's like setting set
up set that time out for yourself and I
had all these excuses when I was in LA
right over and I was working like just
too busy I'm to this and that now I have
no excuse and I'm like well that's a me
problem like I have to I have to like
you know get my affairs in order and
really like established and get
disciplined on my about my routine and
stuff so that's kind of what I've been
trying to work on now is like just
spending time with my loved ones and I'm
learning to play piano right now on my
phone there's like an app on your
phrasing you got to play piano is that
I've never I've never read music I never
knew how to so that's that's I was
always kind of like more ear so it's
nice to be able to do that kind of stuff
and you know just yeah just trying to
trying to stay busy and yeah it's crazy
man it's like I feel like we're in a bad
movie sometimes but yeah you know the
storm will pass you know at one point so
yes you know well I mean for someone
that doesn't read music nearly a million
streams for their song is a pretty good
that's a pretty good get let me be your
whiskey like 900 that was about a
thousand plus yeah right like in like it
yeah in like a
it was stupid like for like I understand
that for like pop music and for like
hip-hop and all that's like you can have
a billion streams right but like for
country music where a lot of the
audience still listens to radio to like
that's a that's amazing
I was like I was so like just like I'm
so freakin grateful for that and like
that's honestly I like all credit to
like people who have really supported me
along the way that I met in Nashville
that like I kind of was just like hey
this is um this is a huge dream of mine
like isn't this isn't I don't want this
to be some like actor turned musician
story of like oh I expect to hit song
right now so like do it for me like I
love I love country music and like I
always wanted to learn what it took to
write a great song so I kind of start
from the ground up and I think maybe
some people recognize that and you know
I had some amazing support from John
Marx at Spotify Nashville on him
thank you John I'm so grateful for him
because he he put it on like the
playlists like the new boots playlist
and that's what helped get it kind of
out there totally Kennedy and Curt
Allison and Jason Aldean have been huge
supporters and I'm so grateful for them
and and I just you know I can't I so
badly want to but it's led to something
pretty really remarkable for me so I'm
really excited for the future of that
you know so I'm getting the right that's
one thing I'm doing I'm writing a lot of
bad songs right now yeah yeah trying to
find that good one in before you come
out exactly that's super exciting I'm
you know it's cool to have a obviously
have a little secret under your hat but
now we know that something's coming so
we're gonna expect some great things
well I hope so I mean I hope yeah I hope
I hope I hope you like it you know yeah
I love it
yeah at the end of the day it's like I
gotta just you me and if people you know
if people like you then that makes me
happy and that's great you know I want
as many people to hear it that we'll
hear it so so do you think that having a
place in Nashville is in your near
future you think you could go live down
there you know I'm trying to save as
much money other bus we can
like I think like everybody right now
it's like we don't know how long this is
gonna last for and you know I am
certainly counting my blessings right
now and you know I love Nashville I
think the play it's amazing the people
are awesome and like you know God
willing down the road when all this kind
of settles and hopefully I can get back
to work and yeah maybe that isn't the
cards down the road but everything's
kind of been put on hold you know it's
kind of just like there was a it's crazy
because like I was but I was a week away
from starting a show and I was really
excited I mean the show is incredible
and like the writing is just spectacular
and and then I would you know offered a
film after that so it was like really
exciting stuff and it's just I have to
ask myself like what is what's the
lesson here for me like what can I take
from this and it's like I think that you
know so much sorry so much of my um of
like my drive has been my work like I've
been so that's where I get my highs from
is like just working hard like just
getting all that done and now I have to
be alone for a second and actually like
deal with that anxiety and like look
okay I can't distract myself like
there's no that's like okay why can't I
just be happy with just simply being
alive cuz that's like like I have to be
so I should be so grateful you know just
to be here so that's what I'm working on
now I'm really trying to work on like
just gratitude because it's so easy to
get lost and let you know when it's just
go go go go go you know so yeah yeah I
think when you've got ambition it's a
hard thing to sort of like to see
momentum slow down right totally totally
it is it is you feel like you've lost
your eye like like your purpose you know
it's like where's my purpose now like
it's gone and that should never be the
case I think like it's like that should
be a result of more you know like I I
you know I've watched something like
Oprah and stuff and I think that she's a
fascinating person and she always talks
about how everything she got she got her
gratitude you know and like really
understanding that is like yeah like I
they would just you know this is more
than enough but if now is all it is
that's more than you know I'm so damn
lucky to be and I'm sure you feel the
same way it's like I'm sure a lot of
people do right now and that's the thing
is I think that like you know again like
not to get so I didn't expect this to
get so deep but but I think that you
know there's no doubt that this has just
been so awful for so many people and I
just can't even imagine being in a
position where you're living paycheck to
paycheck right now and that's just just
awful
there really aren't any words to
describe what they must be going through
right now
mm-hmm if there is any silver lining in
this at all it's that it's reminding
people certainly it's reminding me now
to speak for my own my own self is that
is what's really important in life and
that's your friends family your health
you got those you know you're living a
hell of a life yeah one of the one of
the media figures that I like to look to
not even when it's times like these but
kind of in general is will oh yeah
you've worked so close with them and
you're you guys are on social media
together you guys are talking back and
forth yeah have you as a group connected
about what we're going through right now
or talked about the different situations
y'all are in I actually texted him like
two days ago and I was just like are you
I was like how you holding up because I
would just we were talking about you
know the potential of a sequel and
actually I think I can say that because
they I think they actually announced
that so yeah and like what that would
look like and stuff and I just had got
off the phone with the producers and I
just shot well the text and was like
dude like I'm so excited about this
sounds like things are coming along
swimmingly and you know how are you
holding up and you know well as I agree
like he's always been somebody that I've
looked up to in that sense like like
when we shot bad boys he he I think I
said I don't know if I told you this
right or somebody he basically told he
built this whole gym for the cast and
the crew and I mean it was like for
anyone to use you know and for me I've
realized that working out isn't just
aesthetic like I need to do it for my
mental health like I have to work out
everyday like it's like it's just to
stay sane because I have a crazy mind so
and I think that that was kind of a kiss
gift to everybody to give them an
opportunity to do that and I mean it was
like fully equipped with cryofreeze like
a pool like if they didn't even sing I
don't think and I mean that's the kind
of guy he is he has the ability to do
something like that and he does it but
the coolest thing I think he did was
that in that gym
he had shelves of books and it was his
favorite books and multiple copies of
them that he's read and a lot of them to
my surprise and looking back I'm not I
shouldn't have been surprised at all
were where self-help books you know it's
like they were I mean obviously you had
like The Alchemist in there and stuff
but like things like but there were
books that I didn't I wasn't surprised
to see what I did but I guess I wasn't
expecting that and I realized that like
Will has just mastered his career
because I believe he's mastered himself
and his life you know like he worked so
hard on that so I think that he's again
like somebody a hundred percent I look I
look up too immensely especially in a
time like this you know and Jada is well
like if you look at her like Instagram
and stuff like she's posting her
favorite books and she's talking about
things that you know she's trying to do
to include people in their process as
they go through it as well which i think
is rare yeah I spoke to Vanessa
yesterday too actually and she's and
she's doing well as well she's she's
quarantine with her mom I think in LA
and you know and I spoke to Charles as
well we've all become like such a close
family like I just I love them all so
much it's like it's insane